action anime typically gives us the
theme of overcoming odds that seem
insurmountable
sometimes this comes in the form of a
long journey and other times our heroes
go through setbacks or deal with their
inner demons then there are the times
when the said insurmountable odds are
represented by literally a huge hulking
creature or people that stand as a
roadblock or maybe these big things are
just there to show that the hero or the
villain in question is really just that
strong in this video we'll take a look
at some of the coolest moments and
fights featuring a character taking on
someone twice or even thrice their size
as the saying goes size does matter
except when it doesn't
first on the list at number 10 its
Saitama versus Marui Gouri while this
technically counts as a man vs. giant
fight I'm not sure if I'd call this a
fight in the first place
in one of his first battles Saitama
faces the gigantic mutant Maru Gori
having just killed his brother in one
shot by accident
Maru gory wastes no time and loading on
Saitama he releases a barrage of punches
with his impressive body before
declaring victory in a sentimental
speech only to find out that the fights
not over not by a long shot
the fights decided in classic one punch
man fashion that's all that needs to be
said about this squash match after all
think you know just got up in a while
Simba
suited
cool
midoriya taking on the giant robot is
number 9 on our list let's just say that
midoriya was the underdog before this
fight the quickest hero comes into the
UA entrance exam and finds he's sitting
on a miserable zero points as the test
draws to a close
nevertheless a giant robot worth zero
points appears giving midoriya his
chance to shine despite showing its
strength by smashing buildings and
trapping which echo the robot doesn't
unnerved midoriya the green haired hero
rises up and delivers a powerful punch
showcasing his quirk one for all for the
first time
xico detail fish tyotka
number eight we have Belk ran'l and the
adventurers versus black Goliath the end
of the first season of danmachi features
Belle and his fellow adventurers taking
on black Goliath at the beginning of the
fight things don't look good for our
heroes black Goliath proves too much for
them and after barely being saved by
ogre sacrifice the team get time to
regroup on the bright side round two
turns out much better with everyone
cooperating they slowly wear down black
alive before Belle lands the decisive
finisher is this the best final battle
we can have for Dan matches first season
in some ways I would argue it is
come on the earliest enough you bested
us eagerly
the seventh battle on our list is s
death and Tatsumi battle against the
danger beasts in episode 14 while
Tatsumi takes down a beast that towers
over him by stabbing its weak spot as
death follows up by dismantling one with
her ice powers not only does she defeat
the danger beast she crushes it under
the weight of a chunk of ice even bigger
than the already gigantic monster as
Tatsumi notes she's on an entirely
different level from the eyes of the
onlooker she's more of a monster than
the Giants that dare to step in her way
ha
in the six but we take a look at not
suit versus the God of War the cultists
leaders no match for the fire dragon
slayer
but his trump cards the so-called God of
War a humungous God that he summons
through a sacrifice done beforehand
luckily for Natsu though and the rest of
the good guys gigantic enemies like the
God of War are nothing in the face of
the power of friendship undeterred by
the size and the intimidating presence
of this new foe Natsu begins climbing
the giant despite the cult leaders claim
that attacks are futile against the
mighty God of War Natsu launches an
explosive attack on top of the God of
War completely obliterating its body
just another day in the life of Fairy
Tail
before we continue I'd like to thank
crunchyroll who've kindly sponsored this
video crunchyroll the world's largest
destination for anime and manga with
your favorite shows like attack on titan
my hero academia and fairy tale sign up
at crunchyroll.com slash of any tube or
click the link in the description and
you'll get crunchyroll premium free for
14 days
crunchyroll premium doesn't just offer
ad free full HD content but listen to
this they also release the newest
episodes as soon as one hour after airs
in Japan via simulcast I've been
watching JoJo's bizarre adventures
latest season on crunchyroll which has
been absolutely amazing so if you
haven't checked it out yet
you're in luck just use my link
crunchyroll.com / mini tube and binge
the whole series right now taking the
5th place on the list is the fight
between seijuro and Fuji in the Ruhr oni
Kenshin universe
Fuji's easily a beast he's a mere
moments away from putting an end to
yahiko much to everyone's horror as the
kid calls out Kenshin's name who better
to answer the call than his master and
the most powerful character in the
series Kiko seijuro making a grand
entrance he answers the gargantuans
opponents challenge after easily
avoiding a devastating attack in using
the Giants eyes against their best
seijuro finishes the fight with one
attack one attack is all it takes
[Music]
[Music]
coming in at number 4 we have Goku vs.
hero daguan hero daguan star of the
Dragon Ball Z movie wrath of the Dragon
is probably the closest the series has
to a generic doomsday villain you know
the ones that just kill and destroy
things without reason
here are the guns basically that just a
being of destruction oh and he's really
big for his size his feats in the movie
won't disappoint he brings his size and
power into play and gives the Z warriors
a run for their money
everything the heroes throw at him only
serves to facilitate his transformation
after a fierce battle that features
another attempt in sealing him hero
deagan's finally defeated for good Goku
destroys the monster with super dragon
fist
third place on the list is the battle
against incarnate of the radius in sword
art online ordinal scale want to treat
for Sao fans ordinal scale gives out a
present in the form of the climactic
fight against incarnate of the radius
let's just say that the thing is insane
befitting its status as the ultimate
enemy
besides insane stats and powerful
abilities the gigantic boss monster
boasts the power of regeneration
rendering previous efforts to fight it
null in a flash as the characters points
out no one would be able to beat that
thing it took you a returning and giving
the crew their old gear back as well as
bringing it everyone from all the games
the core group played in order to bring
the boss down in one spectacle of a
final fight that you just have to watch
this movie for
[Music]
[Music]
number two on the list is luffy vs had
ribbon need a way to make your main
character look strong look no further
than the resident giant supporting
character on the cast an arrogant
warrior who seeks to become the king of
the giant [ __ ] Rudin fights as a
gladiator in the corridor Coliseum
nothing can stand in this mighty Giants
way unfortunately for him his path
crosses none other than monkey dee Luffy
even with a seemingly insurmountable
size advantage and a first move that
looks like it's ended the fight quickly
the table's get turned and Hagler then
gets taken care of by Luffy in one punch
[Music]
standing tall at the top of our list is
the battle between Levi and the beast
Titan in one of the high points of
attack on Titan season 3 levi confronts
the beast titan in an epic duel duel
might be stretching it though as the
fight simply showed us once more while
Levi is indeed humanity strongest
soldier Levi waste no time in
systematically dismantling the beasts
tightened down to size he's no stranger
to fighting Titans for his relentless
assault coming off the heels of one of
the biggest sacrifices in the series is
something that we've yet to witness with
no time to mount a successful defense
the beast Titan gets destroyed by
humanity's strongest soldier
[Applause]
[Music]
want to check out more of Levi's
awesomeness sign up for crunchyroll
premium using my link crunchyroll.com
slash mini tube that's a VI n III t ube
or you can just click in the link in the
description it's available on pretty
much all devices including iOS Android
PlayStation Xbox and more so go and
check it out now need a way to make a
character look strong look no further a
Giants on the way on a more serious note
we'd love to hear from you about this
topic if you want to don't hesitate to
throw in some more man vs giant fights
that we can take a look at don't forget
to leave a like if you enjoyed the video
and subscribe if you haven't already
I'll see you next time on vide tube
[Music]
[Music]